what's up guys more it's Sovereign back
again for iron Lord's podcast and Boards
of gaming.net I'm here with Steve and EJ
and we're looking at Russell's story
from Tick Tock games yeah tell us a
little bit about Russell store yes thank
you guys for coming by by the way so
wrestle story is a turn-based wrestling
RPG it's inspired by all the games that
we love growing up you know Chrono
Trigger Final Fantasy Paper Mario series
and my love of pro wrestling I grew up
watching pro wrestling my whole life
it's a part of who I am I love playing
the game and I was like man I really
want a story in pro wrestling so this
game is all about living your story you
make your character you go out and you
like make your name for yourself as a
wrestler and you might get into some
craziness along the way so tell me a
little bit about how the like the
systems work yeah yeah it's sort of the
the background stuff okay we're getting
right into the systems I love that it's
it's I'm looking at it
yeah and obviously we'll get into the
combat in a second but yeah
wait what type of thing yeah so so like
I said it's a turn-based RPG so we have
all the trappings of return based RPG
your characters all have stats you have
different types of characters that you
can spec out with skill trees they have
all unlockable move sets gear we can
show you some of that in a sec but
basically if you're used to games like
Final Fantasy
um you're gonna feel right at home right
it's got all the systems that you're
used to there plus it's got action
command-based combat right so similar to
games like Paper Mario or South Park
Stick of Truth where you're timing out
your attacks based on the attack you're
doing so for example you're gonna see
like a body slam you hold up on the
stick and then you slam down so we're
really trying to create that connection
between wrestling and like the feeling
of slamming somebody with a turn-based
game so I think you're gonna see it it
plays pretty quickly compared to some
other RPGs that's amazing so when you
think about the combat and stuff is it
always in the ring or do you have
backstage Shenanigans oh yeah in terms
of story you know
thing that goes up and down
combat yeah foreign
that's the whole thing our game a fight
can happen anywhere right you could be
in like a bar and a rainbow pop up
around you right a referee will slide
out of nowhere like that's our joke the
referee can just appear out of nowhere
you're like what the heck where'd this
guy come from right
um it can happen anywhere as far as like
the background drama every single
episode of our show right it's kind of
it's framed in an episodic way right so
as an episode comes up you get
introduced to a new heel right you're
gonna learn about them they're gonna cut
a promo on you you're gonna get the
opportunity to cut a promo back on them
so you're picking your dialogue options
you're kind of cutting them down and as
you build up over that episode You're
Building to that inevitable big fight
like you see in a wrestling match and
then we have these long-term story lines
where you're just you're taking on a
bunch of heels in a row that are leading
to one massive like super bad guy right
so that's amazing is that voice active
or is its effect
um so all of it is text right now so
it's fully obviously like text with the
sound effects and everything will add
little runs and stuff like that we'll
talk a little bit more about potential
voice acting later some some of it might
be voice acted but yeah
so we're actually using Unity we've been
using Unity for a really long time as a
studio it's something we're really
comfortable with
um so we have a good relationship with
those guys we really like their engines
yeah would you mind just describing
exactly what PJ's doing right now yeah
so right now PJ just arrived to one of
the five major territories in the game
the game is broken up into five
different like wrestling hubs right so
this one is sort of influenced by Miami
a little bit it's got kind of the
Florida Vibe which is a really big
wrestling Hub right you go to other
places like gnocchio which is kind of
like our stand-in for Tokyo we have San
Lucha which is our standing for Mexico
City we have like our Texas stand-in so
you're going to go to places that you
recognize but they'll have our kind of
Brussels story spin on them a little bit
absolutely so he's he's coming in here
and one of our major heel factions has
ruined Paradise City right he's taking
it from Paradise City to his party city
so this is a party King who is the
leader of the Knights of the beer pong
table and they're kind of this this
faction of like college frat guys right
who are just like partying in the
streets causing chaos annoying everybody
in the city and you'll see there's kind
of a reason for it as you go but right
now you're just dealing with these jerks
on the
streets yeah
thank you we'll be part of yeah are you
just a single player or do you have
Parts yeah so your the whole thing is
you're building up your faction you get
to name your faction take like your
color scheme and your Vibe your best
friend Carlo who you grew up with as a
tag team he's a little bit reluctant
about adding people into the crew but as
you go he starts to kind of welcome
people in and they have all different
kinds of abilities like we have Harmony
who is kind of a tank character she she
plays it a little bit smarter
um we have Carlo like I said who's kind
of more of like a flamboyant rock star
type of character he he Hypes the crowd
he actually heals you with his hype
right so you know in wrestling when
you're like you get that baby face fire
and you're like right like we're like
Hulk Hogan getting the the so he helps
you to build that hype and heal your
whole party that's amazing yeah so when
it comes to the combat are you just is
it one-on-one matches or do we have tag
team matches do you have crazy and stuff
like you know you know
yeah yeah so the cool thing about art
game is that in wrestling the win
condition can be many things right it
could be a pin it could be a submission
but it can be climbing up a ladder and
pulling a briefcase down right so in our
game we touch on all that stuff the
primary mode is elimination so you're
going to eliminate your opponents one by
one with like pins
um but as you go on there's going to be
different scenarios where you're
climbing up a ladder and matching up to
try to get to the thing first before the
enemy gets there and a few other
unannounced matches that we have okay
yeah
oh man so we don't have an announce date
right now but we're working super hard
on it we're hoping to get a little bit
more funding to push it over the edge
right but right now we don't have an
announce State basically the answer that
we're giving is when it's ready when
it's fun when you guys like it you know
that's that's what we want absolutely
thank you so much yeah
thank you so much guys this is going
Sovereign again this is Russian story
this is Steve this is TJ this is
Russell's Story coming to you live from
Taxi 2023 iron Lords podcast from Lords
of gaming.net yeah